[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the fast Fourier transform and solving
PDEs and in the last video I showed you
how to solve the heat equation using the
fast Fourier transform and the heat
equation is kind of the perfect example
of when to use the Fourier transform for
you transform was invented as an
eigenvector coordinate transformation
for the heat equation okay that's why
the the Fourier transform is here today
is because of the heat equation but here
I'm going to show you how to solve a
couple of other PDEs using the FFT so
I'm gonna start with the one-way wave
equation u T plus C u x equals zero okay
this is a really really simple PDE
where if you have some some shape like
this Gaussian that Gaussian is just
gonna travel from left to right at a
constant speed see this wave speed C
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
going to Fourier transform this PDE just
like before we're gonna Fourier
transform you in space to get u hat we
can still take its time derivative so
the time derivative of U hat is going to
be minus C times the derivative of u u X
but u X is I times Kappa times u hat so
now in my Fourier transform domain this
derivative term this UX just becomes an
I times Kappa times u hat okay so this
is going to be really simple to solve in
the Fourier domain we're literally going
to take our state vector is going to be
u hat at all of those frequencies and
we're going to step that you hat forward
using an OD e integrator in Python
according to this ordinary differential
equation this is a system of ordinary
differential equations for every Kappa
and we're gonna walk this forward using
an Eau de integrator or Runge Kutta
integrator okay and this Kappa is a
vector of frequencies u hat is a vector
of Fourier coefficients and and that's
how we're gonna solve this okay just
like we did for the heat equation so
let's fire up our Jupiter notebook here
and again this was translated from our
MATLAB codes by danielle de loose key
and so I really like his version of this
code ok just like before what we're
going to do is
we are going to set up our domain over
here so we're gonna have a domain from
minus 10 to 10 so the length is 20 with
a thousand points we're going to define
the discrete wave numbers determined by
that spatial domain so the pub defined
by that length and that number of points
we're gonna have an initial condition
which is a hyperbolic secant which is
basically another way of getting a
Gaussian hyperbolic secant is a nice way
of getting a Gaussian we're gonna
Fourier transform it to get our initial
condition in the Fourier domain
okay Fourier transform Gaussian is
another Gaussian and then we're going to
use this right-hand side function so
this is the exact same right-hand side
function that we were writing down here
where the derivative of U hat in time is
minus C times I times Kappa times u hat
okay so that's our derivative right hand
side and then we're going to solve that
right hand side OD e with OD e int using
a 4th order Runge Kutta scheme and
that's gonna give me my my u hat okay
now you don't worry about this
alternatively code down here I'll talk
about this in a minute we're gonna solve
this in the Fourier domain to begin with
and when we do that then we're going to
inverse Fourier transform and make some
of these plots and this is kind of a
visualization of that wave moving from
left to right it's a little harder to
see in this perspective so I sometimes
like the top-down view where you look at
the the function U of X and T in this X
T diagram and here you can see clear as
day that this wave is moving from left
to right at a constant wave speed okay
so the wave is not degrading it's not
changing this shape is staying exactly
the same it's just moving from left to
right at this constant constant wave
speed okay so that's a nice way of
solving this PDE in Python by Fourier
transforming and working in the Fourier
transform domain so that's kind of the
first thing we just did was we solve the
whole PDE in the Fourier transform
domain
and then at the very end we inverse FFT
D to get our state back whereas the
inverse FFT here so once we had the
solution we inverse FFT to every frame
of our movie just for plotting okay now
there's this part here that says
alternatively we could simulate in the
spatial domain I think this is really
important and I want to point out how
you would do this okay so this is kind
of the second approach we could take
here technically I can solve this system
in the spatial domain I can solve I
don't have to Fourier transform and
integrate uhat forward I can integrate
this big vector U at every point in
state forward in time but I'd have to
find some way of approximating UX this
derivative here so what we're gonna do
in this code this alternative code is
we're still going to use the Fourier
transform to compute the derivative so
we're gonna take you we're gonna map
into the Fourier domain u hat we're
gonna take the Fourier transform we're
gonna compute the derivative just like
we always do by eye kappa u hat but then
we're gonna inverse Fourier transform to
get UX back in the spatial domain and
then our right hand side function is
just minus C times UX that we computed
in in the Fourier derivative so you can
technically simulate your PDE up here in
the spatial domain but we can
approximate this derivative using the
FFT this spectral derivative so it's
gonna be fast and accurate okay so
technically you can solve the PDE and
either of these spaces it's not a big
deal to go back and forth I would say
this is a little bit more efficient
because once you take your initial
condition into the Fourier domain now
you're only working in the Fourier
domain and you only come out at the very
end when you want to plot something
whereas here at every single time step
when we evaluate this right-hand side
function I'm moving into the Fourier
domain to compute the derivative and
then back out of the Fourier domain to
get it back in space so this requires to
FFTs at every single time step which
which is more expensive okay but it's
still a better way of computing this
derivative than using some kind of a
finite difference or central different
stencil which would be you know much
more inaccurate
okay so the FFT is kind of the most
accurate and still a very efficient way
of simulating this even in the spatial
domain and the reason I'm showing you
this this alternative is because this is
how we're going to solve nonlinear PDEs
okay so in the in the last example I'm
going to walk you through we're gonna
solve the burgers equation I'm gonna
write this down so it's still a
one-dimensional wave-like equation we
have UT plus u times UX equals some
constant nu times u xx okay this is
burgers equation it's a really really
nice example of the kinds of things you
can get in a real fluid flow like the
navier-- stokes equation this is kind of
a one dimensional analog of navier's
stokes of the fluid equations and what
we're gonna do doesn't begin we're gonna
just ignore this diffusion term here and
act like we just had u t plus u u x
equals zero okay and if we had no
diffusion here it would look a lot like
this one-way wave equation except the
wave speed is now u it's proportional to
the wave height the amplitude U and so
now I would have my wave and it's still
gonna move from left to right but the
higher the value of U the faster that
wave speed is so this point is gonna
move faster than this point and as this
moves from left to right that I didn't
draw it very well it's going to steep in
on the right-hand side the the top is
gonna move faster than the bottom and so
it's gonna get steeper and steeper and
eventually it's gonna form this very
very very sharp shock wave okay so this
is actually a nice model of how shock
waves can form in fluid flows okay this
is like a model of avalanches and other
kinds of shock waves and if we didn't
have this diffusion term this would only
get steeper and steeper and steeper this
or just get worse and worse and worse in
time because of this non-linearity and
it would become eventually kind of
infinitely steep shock wave and so
that's why we add this diffusion term
this is what's called a regularizing
diffusion term or a regularizer
and regular rising
diffusion and it basically is a term
that tries to diffuse out that shock
formation so it's balancing out this
steepening mechanism this is trying to
kind of flatten everything out and
smooth it out and so these two are
balancing each other and the diffusion
is regularizing the problem so that this
shock can't form infinitely steep okay
and so what eventually happens when you
have this regularizing term is that you
still have this steepening of the shock
wave but it can't get infinitely steep
it's kind of hard to draw these but it
can't get infinitely steep there will be
some finite width of that shock wave
because if it gets too steep then it's
going to have extremely high second
derivatives and this term is going to
kind of flatten those out because
remember the diffusion operator hates
high frequency terms and this shock wave
is a very very high has high frequency
components so the steeper that shock
forms the bigger these gradients become
and the more that this diffusion is
trying to kind of fight that that that
shock forming so these are balancing
each other and giving giving a shock
wave now the reason I'm telling you
about this it's first of all it's an
interesting partial differential
equation but we're going to see how you
can use the FFT to solve even nonlinear
PDEs like this one okay and we're gonna
solve it kind of like how we did up here
we're gonna solve it in the spatial
domain so we're gonna advanced u as a
function of X so a big vector of U for
all positions X we're going to advance
that in time but we're going to use the
FFT to compute all of these derivatives
very very accurately and efficiently
that's the key is we're going to
approximate everything on the right hand
side and of course I can move this term
over and it's a right hand side we're
going to approximate those derivatives
using the FFT okay so I'm going to go to
my my burgers example here and pretty
much nothing has changed we have the
same domain same number of points same
kappa vector same initial condition and
now this right-hand side burgers is the
only thing that's changed so what we're
going to do is we're going to
take our system state you we're gonna
Fourier transform it to get you hat then
we're gonna compute the first and second
derivatives because we need both of
those and then we're going to inverse
for you transform those to get them back
in terms of a function of space of X
okay so we're going to compute our
derivatives in the Fourier domain then
we're going to inverse Fourier transform
to get them back as functions of the
state very state variable X then we can
compute this whole right-hand side it's
just minus u times D u u times u X plus
nu times u xx okay so we're only using
the FFT here to efficiently and
accurately approximate these derivatives
and then we're gonna solve the we're
gonna advance the state of the system
forward in time just using a know de
integrator okay so that's what we're
seeing here and here is our kind of
waterfall diagram where you can see our
Gaussian is evolving at time and it is
in fact steepening you can see that the
blue curve is steeper on the the front
than it was and if you look at the
top-down view if you plot this like an
image you can actually see very clearly
that as this wave is evolving from left
to right it's also steepening this this
very very sharp edged front is forming
at the at the rightmost boundary but it
can't become infinitely sharp because of
this regularizing diffusion effect if I
got rid of this term basically this
system would get steeper and steeper and
steeper and steeper until my numerix
failed and the system would kind of blow
up numerically okay
but this regularizing term keeps that
shock from getting infinitely sharp okay
good okay and so I think that is what I
wanted to show you and I'm just gonna do
a quick recap we can solve these PDE s
kind of as a big system of Odie's that
that's how we think of PDE s numerically
is I can take U which is the state of my
system and I can discretize it on a
spatial grid so I can basically get U at
X 1 at X 2 and X 3 a big vector of my
state at all of my locations so you know
this would be my
you know Gow and might look like that in
in space okay
and what I can do is I can walk this
forward using OD e int sum OTE
integrator OD 45 some Runge Kutta scheme
forward Euler any integration scheme you
like to integrate something forward in
time you can just think of this as the
state of the system and this is the
system of ordinary differential
equations for every row of your state
now you can approximate those right-hand
side vector fields efficiently those
derivatives accurately and efficiently
using the FFT that's that's one way to
do that okay but another thing you can
do is you can actually work in the
Fourier coefficients themselves so you
can take your initial conditions
sometimes you can Fourier transform and
you can integrate the system directly in
in Fourier space so at least in the case
of a linear partial differential
equation like the linear wave equation
or the linear heat equation you can
Fourier transform into the Fourier
domain and you can solve your system
forward in time in in Fourier
coefficients the state of your system is
your big vector of Fourier coefficients
you can integrate those forward in time
you can step those forward in time and
then when you're ready to plot your
system or do some analysis in space you
just inverse Fourier transform back so
you can go kind of Fourier transform to
get down and then once you have your
system at some later time you hat later
you can inverse Fourier transform to get
back to your spatial state at some later
time okay so you can always go from from
a function of space to a function of
frequencies you can integrate in either
of these spaces in time and you can go
back and forth any way you like okay so
sometimes it's easier to do one than the
other but the real big point here is
that we can use the FFT to approximate
all of these derivatives accurately and
efficiently so that we can step our
system forward in time okay thank you